[Musique]
oui
c'est que vous avez la new york qui nous
accompagne depuis 34 ans qu'elle a des
niveaux tels que malgré les prêts pour
qu'on donne sur permanence à un niveau
de douleur de ces petites sur l'iss
malgré les traitements sa marque un
moment donné il meurt que leur santé
tels que ça ne l'est qu'en qu'un des
crises de communion
mais la sérénité vous soulignez plus
supportable je suis réveillé cinq à six
fois par nous parler de douleur et que
ce sera exactement donc la liste
nuuk du sud est reportée au 4
cette norme l'arrêt de tout traitement
le tout choix
le tout alimentation et le tout
hydratation c'est ce que permet la loi
et les bidons de l'apic
comme je ne suis pas au stade ultime de
ma vie je pourrais encore traîner des
années et je n'ai pas croire la sédation
profonde toute manière j'en veux pas
moi je partir conscient
[Musique]
elle